[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
evan rachel wood is showing off her
impressive singing chops great oh cool
no pressure on the tonight show the
actress shocks jimmy fallon with her
spot on singing impressions of a few
iconic female artists first up none
other than the material girl herself
madonna
[Music]
which is super fitting considering evan
is playing madonna in the upcoming weird
out yankovic biopic do you talk like
madonna how does madonna talk well it
was a specific madonna you know it's
early 80s madonna and early 80s madonna
she she really you know she was very
nasally and everything she said was very
intentional and um she disarms everyone
that interviews her by
just sort of looking at wow yeah that
role was perfectly cast i love madonna
now they might want to reach out to evan
if there's ever an alanis more set
biopic because that's another impression
she completely nailed
[Music]
and evan didn't stop there she was then
asked to sing some janice joplin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now you'd think with evan's amazing
voice they'd have her seeing some
madonna in the biopic right we had like
a karaoke wrap party and i sang madonna
and then the director goes why didn't i
make you sing in this movie because i i
did i can i can't sing like yeah so
while we wait to see her as the queen of
pop in the film we can catch evan in
season four of westworld
every single day she wakes up
the more she sees it but nobody else can
that there's something wrong with the
world
[Music]
and then it's her fault major spoiler
alert ahead if you haven't seen the
season three finale three
two
one evan's character dolores died i'm
alive i know in a way kind of i mean
dolores isn't right but evan rachel wood
is
and i'm i'm
a different character yep she's coming
back in a new role as christina a writer
and video game programmer when e.t
caught up with the actress earlier this
week she spilled details on her new
persona she's much more human
much more vulnerable
very nerdy
she's just a writer you know
which i'm sure
other things ensue but
without a doubt it is westworld it is
after all do you miss dolores
i do yeah i mean she goes through so
many changes
every season anyway though i feel like
i've already played multiple characters
but this one really was starting from
scratch
[Music]